[Music]
there are so many reasons to be excited
for the second movie and the
wreckit-ralph franchise not only do we
get to see Ralph and vanellope von
schweetz back in action but we get to
see tons of other characters from
various franchises will tell you which
cameos and easter eggs to watch out for
and give you a sneak peek at what comes
next from some of our favorite series
before we get started make sure to click
on the subscribe button for more videos
from the things now let's begin we have
to admit we've been desperately awaiting
the day we could finally see all of our
favorite Disney Princesses together in
one room and we don't just mean that
we've been waiting since the first
trailer for a Ralph's breaks the
internet was released for those of us
who grew up with Disney we had been
waiting for this day since we were kids
and to find out that not only we were
going to see Disney Princesses from
Cinderella to Moana but we would also
see them interacting with one another
and even having a pajama party we don't
think we're overstating it when we say
it's a dream come true the definition of
what makes a Disney Princess has been
pretty controversial for instance many
people wonder why Elsa and Anna from the
movie frozen aren't often included in
this list why is Mulan considered a
Disney Princess but Megara from Hercules
isn't we won't get into it right now but
the short answer is that it has to do
more with merchandising rights than
anything else
Elsa and Anna's source material is so
popular and so lucrative that they exist
in a class all of their own but still we
see them hanging out with the other
Disney Princesses and we even get some
particularly exciting news about them it
seems like the instant frozen came out
fans were already wondering when the
second movie would be released it seems
none of us were capable of simply
letting it go in fact the hype level was
so high that it seems we've been waiting
for the sequel to frozen for almost as
long as we've been waiting for the
Disney Princesses to me and it seems
Disney is well aware of how excited
everyone is about it and just couldn't
resist messing with us a little bit in
the post credit scene of wreck-it Ralph
too according to a voiceover we were
going to get a sneak peek of frozen to
one of the most highly anticipated
movies around we see some animated
snowflakes and
of characters from Ralph breaks the
internet but there's just one small
problem instead of actually providing a
preview for the second frozen movie we
get to hear the character singing the
famous Rick Astley song never gonna give
you up come on you can't have a movie
that takes place on the internet and not
expected to get Rick Rolled or maybe in
this case we would say it was rec roll
we have to admit Disney really got us
good this time
at least we can comfort ourselves with
knowing that frozen 2 is actually going
to happen and we can expect to see it in
theaters in 2019 sure this was a joke
but it definitely still counts as
marketing for frozen - which means we
can expect to see actual trailers and
teasers in the near future and if you
felt bad for being teased by the frozen
2 promo
just think about how wreck-it Ralph
voice actor john c reilly felt when the
studio decided on the idea his job was
over as far as he knew it and he had
left for vacation with his family always
a good sport reilly traveled all the way
to new york city to lend his voice to
the movie one last time before rejoining
his family on vacation now that's
dedication
speaking of trailers one of the most
amusing scenes from wreck-it Ralph -
that we saw before hands definitely had
to be the pancake eating bunny the clip
features an adorable cartoon bunny
eating pancakes and Ralph's feeding it
until it explodes this act terrified the
little girl playing the game on her iPad
but it definitely made us laugh however
surprisingly we didn't see it in the
movie but if you stuck around after the
credits you've got a chance to see it on
the big screen in fact we even get a
pretty funny meta nod to the fact that
Disney has a habit of not including
marketing material in their films and if
you're a particularly eagle-eyed Disney
fan you may have noticed that the baby
looks awfully familiar
if you thought this little girl strongly
resembles baby Moana you're not alone
Disney has been criticized for using
similar looking characters in the past
but this time we have to believe it was
on purpose the voice actress who plays
Moana Ally eek ravallo also provided the
voice for the baby's mother in wreck-it
Ralph - this definitely leads us to
believe this was an intentional
- the movie Moana the mother calls the
baby mo which makes us wonder if this is
supposed to be a baby Moana but wait how
can grown-up Moana be inside the
Internet while baby Moana is playing on
a tablet well let's just attribute this
to some good old-fashioned Disney magic
the story of why this popular scene
didn't make it into the movie is
actually pretty interesting
according to producer Clarke Spencer the
team felt confident it was going to fit
in - Ralph breaks the Internet when the
trailer was released but pretty much as
soon as the trailer was released the
scene got cut
Spencer claims story's evolved over time
and this movie changed too much since
its inception that pancake milkshake
just didn't belong any longer not will
need this scene show up in the trailer
but toys featuring the bunny had already
been produced so the studio pretty much
had to include it at some point
Disney has been known for their
princesses for decades but recently
they've added even more popular
franchises to their repertoire the
company now has the rights to many of
our favorite Marvel movie characters
after the events of Avengers infinity
war our feelings were pretty raw to be
honest but needless to say were greatly
looking forward to the fourth film in
the Avengers franchise
sadly in addition to everyone who
perished when Thanos snapped his fingers
we also said goodbye to someone else who
was a hero to Minnie and that's comic
book legend Stan Lee this comic genius
co-created many of our favorite Marvel
characters including spider-man The
Incredible Hulk and the x-men he also
became the face of Marvel Comics and
fans look forward to seeing his iconic
cameos in many major movies but in
addition to Marvel Studios he's also
made appearances in everything from
Mallrats to big hero 6 I wear em front I
wear em back he also made a brief
appearance in Ralph's break the internet
when vanellope bumps into him while
running from stormtroopers although this
was simply an animated avatar of Stan
Lee if you're aching for more cameos
you're in luck apparently Stan Lee
wasn't much for travelling and preferred
to film several cameos on one trip
according to Marvel Studios he filmed a
few prior to his passing we know he will
make an appearance in the movie
spider-man into the spider-verse
where we will get to see him deliver
some dialogue to the protagonist Miles
Morales
Marvel fans are hoping this won't be the
last of his cameos and we might even get
to see him one last time in the movie
Avengers 4 as you probably guessed by
the appearance of stormtroopers Disney
also owns the popular Star Wars
franchise there were tons of Star Wars
Easter eggs in the movie but there is
one which didn't make it into the final
cut of the movie according to the
director rich Moore he originally wanted
to include a joke about the Star Wars
villain kylo Ren it was going to make
fun of him for being spoiled and
childlike but more decided to run it by
Lucasfilm first but perhaps
unsurprisingly Lucasfilm didn't think
the joke was particularly funny
they asked Moore not to poke fun at kylo
Ren out of respect for their franchise
so unfortunately we know there is at
least one joke from Ralph Frakes the
internet which will never get to hear
speaking of franchises we love from our
childhood Disney also came out with a
movie called Christopher Robin based on
the book Winnie the Pooh Christopher
Robin that perpetually sat in down
donkey ER is voiced by actor Brad
Garrett not only do we get to see a or
show up in Ralph's rake the internet but
he's also voiced by Brad Garrett's this
time as well but if you were paying too
much attention to our friend Eeyore you
might have missed some of the other
exciting Easter eggs in the scene in the
background we see marbles Iron Man
flying by hopefully getting ready for
the fourth Avengers movie and he's far
from the only Avengers reference we
spotted there was Captain America shield
and Ironman Scotland as well and that's
just a few of them he may not be a
superhero but Pixar fans loved getting
to see a version of the company's
infamous luxo lamp although with the
lack of scale it's hard to tell if we're
looking at luxo jr. or what so senior if
you love Pixar movies you must have been
in heaven seeing all the pics are
references in Ralph's breaks the
internet we spotted Woody and Buzz
Lightyear from the Toy Story franchise
Eve from wall-e and Arlo from the good
dinosaur like pretty much everyone else
we can't wait to see the upcoming movie
Toy Story 4 so catching a glimpse of
good old Buzz and Woody was particularly
exciting yes we admit we're ready to cry
our eyes out over a movie about toys all
over again and let's talk about the
Disney Princesses okay we know we
mentioned them
or but this time we're going more in
depth do you have daddy issues mom
many of the princesses were spotted with
items relating to their source material
when vanellope first encounters jasmine
she's holding on to the lamp where
jeannie lived during the movie Aladdin
we also saw the same lamp over at eBay
being sold for $30 which is a pretty
good deal if you ask us while Cinderella
was ready to do some damage with her
iconic glass slipper we have to say the
most hardcore of the Disney Princesses
with Snow White and we're sure you
remember from the movie she very nearly
lost her life after taking a bite of a
poison apple but not only do we see her
holding one in her hands without any
trace of fear but she also wears a
t-shirt wearing a poison apple on it we
definitely don't remember her being so
hardcore but we're here for it hopefully
she isn't letting her guard down because
we also spotted a glimpse of the Evil
Queen in the mirror behind her if you're
a fan of classic Disney movies we bet
you notice that Mickey Mouse was wearing
his Sorcerer's Apprentice outfit from
the movie Fantasia there are also so
many Star Wars references it's hard to
keep track in addition to the squadron
of stormtroopers we also saw a sand
crawler the Millennium Falcon
the Death Star a TIE fighter an x-wing
and of course r2d2 himself inside
Walter's office we spotted tons of
classic arcade games including pac-man
space invaders Frogger and Dragon's Lair
on the shelf behind Walter we also
caught a glimpse of Yoda and Chewbacca
now we've seen tons of references to
other Disney properties but now let's
look at a throwback to the first
wreck-it Ralph movie at the 17:17 Mart
we saw the exterior of lit wax Family
Fun Center complete with a large sign
this displayed the text happy 5th
birthday Susie Ralph breaks the internet
came out six years after the first movie
and we spotted an all-too-familiar side
outside of lit wax Family Fun Center
this time the sign reads happy 11th
birthday Susie did you notice this happy
birthday wish in either of the wreck-it
ralph movies which one of these Easter
eggs was your favorite be sure to tell
us which one you like the best in the
comment section below
and then click on the subscribe button
to get the latest videos from the themes
thanks for watching and we'll see you
again next time
[Music]